let's go to the phones at (617) 830-4750 and
see what's on people's minds today.
Starting with our color from the five one
six area code.
Who's calling today from five one six.
Hello?
Yeah, that's you.
Hey, how are you David?
Big Fan.
Thanks.
I'm recently started listening.
Love loving analysis.
I just Kinda wanna um, kind of talk about,
um, what I thought of something and how something
else that's going on.
Um, in terms of conservative movement, how
that relates to that.
So the first thing I kind of want to talk
about is the three kind of segments of Donald
Trump or phases you could say where we have
to have debates about how incompetent Ian
is as per, as, as best excuse me, as a president
where we have to talk about it, we have to
debate reality about what he does.
Yeah.
We can't even get to the policy because we
have to spend so much time debating conservatives
on what reality is.
Yes.
What a lie is.
And then another thing I've been noticing
is George Conway familiar with him?
Yes, of course.
Kellyanne Conway's husband who is also an
attorney, a big critic of Trump.
Absolutely.
So I'm seeing more and more conservatives,
obviously Joe Walsh comes out, um, completely
anti-Trump, which again, I don't agree with
him on policy, but I'm all for all for you
know, them recognizing there is complete incompetence
in the White House.
And yes, there needs to be something done.
So I just, I don't know how prominent this
movement is.
Obviously there's a more educated class of
conservatives that realize there's something
wrong here.
Um,
well listen, it's tight and you just
have to look at the numbers.
You know, Trump claims he has 95% support
from Republicans.
If you look at, I don't know what poll he's
looking at, but every poll I look at says
that Trump has between 78 and 80% support
from Republicans.
20% of Republicans is millions and millions
of people who are on the right, but don't
approve of the job that Donald Trump is doing.
And that, that is not insignificant.
Now the question is, can you turn on an election
by getting those people to vote for Democrats?
Probably not.
Which is why the left just has to get its
base out.
We're not going to win by arguing with the,
the Republicans don't like Trump, but hopefully
enough of them will stay home or consider
voting for someone else that it will push,
push the election our way.
Right.
Absolutely.
And just one more.
No, I, I've discussed things with personal
family members who support Trump and most
a lot of people just aren't in the loop.
Like they just got like, I like Trump.
I, they're not really following everything
he does of course, but it's to the point where
I talked to them, you know, they're not very
rigorous, uh, political followers and I'll
be like, I'll make a point of like, oh, fake
news.
Don't believe it.
Like they, they, they just, they just, they
have, he has opened Pandora's box with people
just saying, if I don't have, if I don't agree
with it, I'm just going to outright deny it.
Yeah.
What Trump has done is in the past when you
would confront a republican with something
George W. Bush did and they hadn't heard of
it, they actually had to do a little bit of
thinking to try to find some way to explain
it away and explain why it's actually good
or it maybe didn't happen or whatever.
Donald Trump has actually given sort of like,
it's the opposite of a white flag.
It's almost like a Trump card for lack of
a better term.
Where if someone presents something to you
that either sounds bad or you didn't hear
about it, you just say it's fake and that's
it.
And then you can continue in your, in your
echo chamber and filter bubble and you're
none the wiser.
Exactly.
It's a perfect cop-out and they just keep
touting it because it stems from the top.
So that's all I wanted to say.
All right, thanks.
Please remind me again what your name was.
Michael Cruz.
Michael.
All right Michael, great to hear from you.
Thank you.
All right, take care.